will obviously maximize tourism in the
area and provide significant long-term
economic benefits to his constituency
however it is just one small part of a
much larger program that includes the
121 million pound leveling up funds 46
million pound community renewable funds
to 200 2.5 billion extra money in block
grant a record block grant for the welsh
labor government showing that this
government is committed to strengthening
the union supporting wales and ensuring
that jobs and prosperity flow to all
parts of the united kingdom
chris brown thank you very much mr
speaker one of the problems that we have
in the rhonda is that we have a large
number of former disused uh coal tips uh
one of which as the minister knows last
year slid down into the river it cost us
14 million pounds to rectify that we've
got another five similar tips in the
ronda can we please have some more money
to make sure that we don't have another
abandoned disaster
[Music]
mr speaker the honourable gentleman will
be aware as i said earlier on that this
is a devolved matter but he'll also be
aware that over 2.5 billion pounds ever
extra money has been provided to the
welsh labor government mr speaker if
there are dangerous coal tips in the
right honorable in the honourable
gentleman's constituency then i would
urge him to talk to his colleagues in
welsh labor ask them to provide the
money and get the problem resolved as
quickly as possible it's a lead sacs bit
yeah yeah yeah speaker
thank you mr speaker on my previous
answer i'm hoping to meet the first
minister uh later this week to discuss a
range of issues i'm sure the honourable
lady would agree that the m4 is central
to cross-border connectivity and
improvements are well overdue if we are
serious about leveling up
yeah it's learned sex bit thank you mr
speaker i can see south wales from my
north devon constituency and i'm very
keen to secure a ferry crossing from
ilfricom to south wales popular on both
sides of the bristol channel with
visions ranging from a dylan thomas
literary tour through to a barry booze
cruise will the minister meet with me to
see how to progress this project
[Music]
mr speaker i'm very happy that it used
to be a ferry from tenbi to north devon
back in the old days and i'm very happy
very happy to see it um
i'm i'm very happy to see it riches i
have to say i have to say mr speaker
that until welsh government honors its
2016 manifesto commitment to improve the
m4 the quickest way of us visiting each
other will be a 30 year old ferry
chugging across the bristol channel
before we come to prime minister's
questions i would like to point out the
british sign language interpretation of
proceedings is available to watch on the
parliament live tv we now come to prime
minister's questions jonathan edwards
number one mr speaker
mr speaker
this morning i had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
jonathan ambrose mr speaker the prime
minister will be aware of the
considerable public concern in relation
to the impression that significant
political political donations can help
acquire a peerage the only member for
nahigan india will publish a bill later
today which will prohibit large party
donors from being nominated to the other
place for a period of five years
will you offer full government support
through my honorable friends efforts
mr speaker i will study his proposals
with care uh when the party is opposite
uh commit to stop taking funds from the
unions in order to control their
policies
[Applause]
mr speaker during a recent visit to
barnet hospital
i was told that a e there is routinely
seeing twice the number of people for
which it was designed
thanks to the hard work of staff and big
funding increases the nhs is seeing more
patients and delivering more tests
treatments and operation than at any
time in its history
but what is the government doing to
urgently assist the nhs to tackle
spiraling demand for health care and a
tough winter ahead
i thank my right honourable friend
because
over the uh for for what she does to
represent uh her hospital and i thank
them uh the nhs staff for their amazing
work that they're doing uh we're
supporting them uh by recruiting as she
knows 50 000 more nurses uh putting
another four and a half billion pounds
into the nhs over the rest of this uh
financial year and uh the best thing we
can do to protect our nhs over this uh
winter is everybody to come forward and
get their booster vaccination
we now come to the leader of the
opposition kirstama
thank you mr speaker
trust matters and after the last
fortnight the prime minister's got a lot
of work to do
a central plank in this government's
promise to the north of england is a
crossrail of the north
with at least
an entirely new high-speed rail line
between manchester and leeds
a crossrail for the north
an entirely new line
that is the promise
it's already been made so i don't want
the primes to fobbing off the house
about waiting till tomorrow he can say
today will he stick
by that promise yes or no
[Applause]
he should wait and see what is going to
be announced
tomorrow
because we will
we will produce a fantastic integrated
rail plan i'm not going to spoil it for
them mr speaker why would i we're going
to produce a fantastic autumn
i expect the front bench to behave
better than what in it world
if you don't want to listen to answer
let me know now i do and i cannot hear
when you all show it together we want
better politics i expect bullet better
politics from both sides let's show a
little bit more decorum that we're
seeing at the moment prime minister uh
mr speaker when we produce our
integrated rail plan tomorrow uh people
across the house and across the country
will see what we are doing to cut
journey times uh to make life easier and
better for people in the northeast in
the northwest in the midlands across the
whole of the north of the country and mr
speaker with the biggest program of
investment in rail for a century mr
speaker for a century and what we are
doing mr speaker is we are giving people
in those communities the same access to
commuter type services that people in
the southeast of this country have felt
entitled to for more than a century and
that is going to be leveling up across
the whole of the uk mr speaker
well mr speaker that was a lot of words
but it wasn't a yes
so that's one important promise to the
north that he won't stand by
let's look at another
in february this year the prime minister
told this house
i can certainly confirm
that we are going to develop the eastern
leg as well as the whole of hs2 the
whole of hs2 a new high-speed line
running continuously no gaps between
birmingham and leeds so will the prime
minister confirm that he stands by that
promise
i'm afraid i'm afraid the right
honourable gentleman is in danger of
getting hoists on his own patard and mr
speaker he needs to wait and see uh what
where we announce tomorrow because i
think he will find that the people of
the northeast of the north west be the
people of leeds the people of nottingham
the people of sheffield and the people
of the whole of the north west and the
northeast of this country will benefit
massively uh for what we are from what
we are going to announce
again mr speaker a lot of words but not
a yes
so that's two important promises to the
north that he won't stand by
no wonder trust in the prime minister is
at an all-time low
across the country and belatedly across
this house there is now agreement that
owen patterson broke the rules and that
the government should not have tried to
let him off the hook
many members opposite have apologized
the business secretary has apologized
for his part
the leader of the house has apologized
for his part
but they were following the prime
minister's lead
so will he do the decent thing
and just say sorry for trying to give
the green light to corruption
yes as i've said before it certainly was
a mistake uh to conflate the case of an
into an individual member
no matter how sad with the point of
principle at stake and we do need we do
need a cross-party approach on an
appeals process we also need mr speaker
a cross-party approach on the way
forward and that's why we've tabled the
proposals that we have to take forward
the report of the independent uh
committee for standards in public life
of 2018 uh with those two key principles
uh that everybody in this house should
focus primarily above all on their job
here in this house and secondly that no
one should exploit their position in
order to advance the commercial
interests of anybody else that's our
position mr speaker we want to take
forward those reforms in the meantime
perhaps he could clear up from his
proposals uh from his proposals whether
he would continue to be able to take
money as he did from mishkan doraea and
other legal fans
oh oh oh oh oh oh other crime prime
minister prime minister as you know and
i do remind you it's prime minister's
questions not leader of the opposition's
question
kierstarma
[Applause]
that's not an apology
everybody else everybody else has
apologized for him but he won't
apologize for himself a coward not a
leader
weeks
weeks
weeks
weeks defending corruption
yesterday a screeching last-minute
u-turn to avoid defeat on labour's plan
to ban mps from dodgy second contracts
but waving one white flag won't be
enough to restore trust
and there are plenty of opposition days
to come and we will not let the prime
minister water down the proposals or
pretend that it's job done
we still haven't shut the door on the
revolving door where ministers are
regulating a company one minute and
working for them the next
there are plenty of cases that still
stain this house
there are two simple steps to sorting it
out
proper independence and powers for the
business appointments committee and
banning these job swaps
will the prime minister take those steps
hi minister uh mr speaker i've called as
uh you know and indeed you have called
mr speaker for a cross-party approach to
this and what i think we need
what i think we need to do is to work
together on the basis of the independent
report uh by the committee of standards
in public life uh to take things forward
and indeed to address the appeals
process but what i think everybody can
see mr speaker is it in a classic
loyally way uh the right honourable
gentleman is now uh trying to prosecute
others for exactly the course of action
that he took himself
what i think that what i think the
nation wants to know because his
register is incomplete who paid who paid
mishkan de rea and who paid the 25 000
who's paying him for his
customer
promise
prime minister i don't want to fall out
about it i made it very clear it is
premises questions it's not for the
opposition to answer your question but
whether we like or not those are the
rules the game that we're all into and
we play by the rules don't we and we
respect this house
[Applause]
mr speaker that newfound commitment to
upholding standards didn't last long
and mr speaker here's the difference
when somebody in my party misbehaves i
kick them out
when somebody
when some or older
oh
mr clark
where's robert
i'm
luke
this is not good we lost a dear friend
i want to assure that this house has
learnt from it i don't want each other
to
i don't want each other to be shouted
down i want questions to be respected i
expect the public to actually be able to
hear the questions of the answers
because i'm struggling in this chat i
need no more care stuff
mr speaker somebody in my party
misbehaves i kick them out
when somebody in his party misbehaves he
tries to get them off the hook
i lead he covers up
let's try another issue we know that
owen patterson was a paid lobbyist for
randox we know that he sat in on a call
between randox and the minister
responsible for handling health
contracts we know that randox has been
awarded government contracts worth
almost 600 million pounds without
competition or tender
against that backdrop the public are
concerned that taxpayers money may have
been influenced by paid lobbying
there's only one way to get to the
bottom of this a full transparent
investigation
if he votes for labour's motion this
afternoon
that investigation can start
will he vote for it
or will he vote for another cover-up
[Applause]
i'm very happy to publish all the
details of the randox contract which
have been investigated by the national
audit office already because we were
talking of cover-ups uh i'm sorry mr
speaker uh but we still have not heard
why the honourable gentleman will not
tell them
administer you
don't prime minister i'm not going to be
challenged you may be the prime minister
of this country but in this house i'm in
charge
end of that
pierced arm
mr speaker i think the prime minister
just said he's happy to publish all the
randox papers in relation to these
contracts so we'll take that
and we'll pursue it and i remind the
prime minister when i was director of
public prosecutions i prosecuted mps who
broke the rule
he has been investigated by every
organization he's ever been elected to
that's the difference
billions of pounds of taxpayers money
handed to their mates and donors
tory mps getting rich by working as
lobbyists one not even bothering to turn
up because he's in the caribbean
advising tax havens
and the prime minister
somehow expects us to believe that he's
the man to clean up westminster
he led his troop through the sewers to
cover up corruption
and he can't even say sorry
the truth is that beneath the bluster he
still thinks it's one rule for him and
another for his mates
at the same time as his governor
engulfed in sleeves they're rowing back
on the promises they made to the north
and it's working people who are paying
the price is it any wonder that people
are beginning to think that the joke
isn't funny
mr
anymore
mr speaker it is plain uh from listening
to the to the right honourable gentleman
that he seeks to criticize this
government while refusing uh to explain
his own position and you've ruled on
that mr speaker you've ruled on that mr
speaker i hear you i hear you uh but his
own misconduct uh mr speaker is
absolutely
absolutely clear to everybody his own
misconduct is absolutely clear and
meantime mr speaker we will get on on a
cross-party basis we will get on on a
cross-party basis with taking forward
the business that i've outlined and we
will get on with the business of this
government which is leading the country
prime minister just
i'm suffering to hear
and if it's correct what i've said
it was about leader of the opposition
misconduct we can't i cannot accuse
someone in the miscon
just before the lead of the house gives
me an answer oh i'm trying to say i
cannot hear if it was said i want it
withdrawn if he wasn't i will accept it
i'm just
just a moment
prime minister this i speak i referred
to the right honourable gentleman's
misconduct because that is what he is
guilty of
that is what he is guilty
[Applause]
i don't think this has done this house
any good today
i'll be quite honest i think it's been
i think it's been little tempered i
think it shows the public
that this house has not learned from the
other week i need this house to gain
respect but it starts by individuals
showing respect to each other
right let's go to lee no less we're
going to james grundy
yeah yeah yeah thank you mr speaker
the people of lee have never accepted
our first merger with the rival friendly
rivals but rival town of wigan back in
1973.
could the prime minister tell me
how we could escape the big government
of big wigan by getting our own council
back
prime minister i thank my honourable
friend
and i thank him for his campaign against
against local labor government uh over
taxing and delivering a delivering uh
inadequate services at the local
boundary commission i will look at the
boundary reviews but meantime i will
support him in any way that i can
we know girl to the leader of the snp in
blackfoot
thank you mr speaker you know it used to
always be said that the tory mps were
behind the prime minister but my
goodness look at the gaps on the third
fourth and
fifth benches
mr speaker the rebellion has clearly
started
mr speaker this tory sleaze candle
has now been hitting the headline for
the past 14 days
and yet
it's pretty obvious that the prime
minister spent less than 10 minutes
coming up with yesterday's half-hearted
half-baked and already half botched
proposals these so-called reforms don't
even scratch the surface this sleaze
scandal runs far far deeper month after
month the public have witnessed scandal
after scandal prg's handed to
millionaire donors vip lanes gifted
coveted contracts to tony pals dodgy
donations for luxury holidays and home
renovations the prime minister and his
government have been up to their necks
in sleeves
can the prime minister tell us exactly
which one
which one of these
scandals his proposals would have
stopped
finished
mr speaker
i i i thank the the humble crofter as he
refers to himself
for his question and i would just say
i would just say that what i think we
can do is pursue a cross-party approach
based on the report of the independent
committee on standards in public life
which has much of a profit in it and it
says amongst other things that it's
important that this house uh should be
uh augmented with outside experience of
the world uh it's important that members
of this house should have experience of
the private sector as he does uh and i
think on a cross-party basis we should
proceed with the uh with the the couple
of reforms that i've indicated ian black
thank you mr speaker of course this is
about tony sleeves
and tory corruption and the prime
minister
has basically admitted that not one of
this government's sleaze scandals would
have been stopped by his so-called plan
and perhaps we shouldn't be surprised
considering the prime minister has been
at the rotten core of all these scandals
the trail of sleaze and scandal
all leads back to the funding of the
conservative party
since 2010
since 2010 mr speaker the tory party has
made nine nine of its former treasurers
members of the house of lords every
single one of them has something in
common they have handed over three
million pounds to the prime minister's
party that is the very definition of
corruption it is the public's definition
of corruption will this government
finally accept that this is corruption
or is the prime minister the only person
in the country who is the brass neck to
argue that it was all one big
coincidence prime minister
uh mr speaker i i look i have to say
that uh you know i won't comment on the
missing six hundred thousand pounds from
the snp
from the smp's party accounts but i i do
say mr speaker in all sincerity and and
heeding what you've said earlier on i
think these constant attacks on the uk's
levels of corruption and sleeves do a
massive disservice do a massive
disservice uh to billions of people
around the world who genuinely suffer
from governments that are corrupt who
genuinely have no ability to scrutinize
their mps mr speaker this is one of the
cleanest democracies in the world that
people should be proud of it
thank you mr speaker would the prime
minister join me in celebrating the 50th
anniversary this year of the formation
of the 177 mile path for walkers along
offered dyke which runs through clewid
south and give his support to the
recently launched offers dike rescue
fund to repair and preserve this
monument and nature reserve for future
generations
mr speaker i had a good fortune to walk
off as dyke very recently and i'm
delighted that uh english and welsh
organizations are working together to
protect that fantastic uh national
monument and historic england has
committed to give almost 300 000 pounds
more to that great cause and david
mr speaker
ambulance response times are now the
worst ever
people are waiting for ambulances longer
than ever and with a e's in crisis
patients are stuck in ambulances outside
hospital longer than ever
waiting times aren't statistics they are
people
people often in great pain and in danger
so why is this government closing
ambulance stations in parts of our
country
why is the west midlands ambulance
service closing up to 10 community
ambulance stations in rugby osmistry and
craven arms with this health crisis for
our ambulance services and in our a e's
injured sick and elderly people are
being hit when will the prime minister
deal with this health crisis
prime minister uh mr speaker i i
appreciate that ambulance crews and
ambulance services are doing an amazing
job particularly at this time of year
and i thank them for for what they're
doing uh we are supporting them with
more cash uh another 450 million was
awarded to 120 trusts uh to upgrade uh
their facilities and as he knows we're
putting another 36 billion uh into
dealing with the backlogs which is uh
fundamentally affecting the nhs so badly
at the moment uh through the uh the levy
that we've instituted which i don't
think uh he supported andrew jones thank
you mr speaker domestic heating accounts
for 30 of uk
carbon emissions and i support the
government's incentive scheme to replace
the old gas boilers with environmentally
friendly alternatives
but now we're building more homes than
we have for many many years
can we build upon the success of cop26
and ask really what
what is the progress that is being made
on the standards for new build homes to
make sure that our new homes are fit for
the future
uh
i thank my honourable friend he's
totally right to focus on the issue of
uh of future-proofing homes and making
them low-carbon and by 2025 our future
homes standard will ensure that new
homes produce at least 75 percent fewer
co2 emissions
thank you mr speaker last week i visited
a gp practice in my constituency of
sheffield brightside and hillsborough
and was horrified to hear about the
immune amounts of abuse staff are
currently experiencing their workloads
are under extreme pressure and this is
not helped by the prime minister making
demands about appointments whilst he has
still failed on his manifesto pledge to
recruit six thousand more gps
so will the prime minister apologize for
this broken promise to gps and their
staff who are on the front line working
under ever increasing pressure and
depleted staffing resources
well first of all i want to thank gps
for everything that they're doing
particularly during the booster rollout
but what we're also doing is not just
recruiting uh as many gps as we can uh
but we have 10 000 more nurses this year
than last year 25 000 more healthcare
professionals all together there are
more people mr speaker now working in
the nhs than at any time in its history
and because of because of our investment
the extra 36 billion uh that we're
putting in there will be even more and
i'm afraid that the lady opposite voted
against that investment david
thank you very much mr speaker following
on from cop 26 can we right animal
friend confirm that maximizing carbon
capture and storage capacity across the
whole united kingdom is a priority for
this government
and
i mean despite the doom and gloom and
the the words of rejection
can he also confirm that the acorn
carbon capture storage and hydrogen
project in my constituency of ban from
buchan has a key role to play in this
country's future carbon capture and
storage capacity targets to meet net
zero yeah minister
i thank my right on my own friend and
he's quite right to uh champion carbon
capture and storage which has a great
future in scotland in spite of all the
gloom stirring of the party of the party
opposite the scottish cluster remains on
the reserve and we will continue uh to
study it and and and we hope to bring it
forward in due time murray glendon thank
you mr speaker the river town with its
world-renowned offshore and sub-sea
sectors has been repeatedly sidelined by
this government despite me and others
constantly lobbying ministers for
investment that would massively increase
employment opportunities and help the
uk's transition to next zero however mr
speaker i'm very excited to see our
voice is now being magnified by a new
time task force set up by the local
authorities the port businesses and the
combined authority so will the prime
minister here and now commit his
government to work with us to realize
the full potential of our great river
prime minister i i thank the honourable
lady for her question and she's
absolutely right that the rivertine is a
a massive economic asset for the whole
of the uh of the northeast it has
suffered from historic uh contamination
uh but we're gonna work with the
northeast local enterprise partnership
to invest another six million pounds to
help develop clear plans for sustainable
economic growth along the whole of the
estuary and rich smith thank you mr
speaker crawley constituency was one of
the most negatively affected by the
kovid 19 pandemic but thanks to
significant support
from this government we are seeing
recovery unemployment now beginning to
come down and we look to a confident
future in that vein will my write of all
friend please look favorably on
crawley's
platinum jubilee city status bid
[Applause]
well i'm very grateful to my uh uh
honourable friend i wasn't aware until
today that crawley was uh bidding to
become a city but i will i will look at
it i will look at it and look at it uh
very carefully uh mr speaker and i'm i'm
sure it i'm sure there's an excellent
case in there somewhere
david lyndon thank you
every year a hundred thousand babies are
born premature are sick in the uk
they're admitted to neonatal intensive
care units the prime minister will be we
are that today is world prematurity day
now there's cross-party agreement in
this house to bring forward neonatal
even pay so rather than wait for a
complex controversial employment bill
will the prime minister bring along
alongside a stand-alone bill to
legislate for this so that next world
prematurity day the 100 000 babies and
their parents don't have to choose
between spending time in the hospital or
unfairly for work
i i thank the honorable general i know
he's a passionate campaigner in uh this
area and uh one way or another and i'll
get back to him on the exact way mr
speaker we will legislate to allow
parents of children in neonatal care to
take extended leave giving them more
time during the most vulnerable and
stressful days of their lives chris
thank you mr speaker further education
colleges like hotwood hall in my hayward
and middleton constituency will play an
essential part in building back better
the team at hotwood have supported over
8 000 learners on courses as diverse as
small business management and animal
management as well as six new t-level
courses so can i invite my right
honourable friend to come and visit the
inspirational team and the students at
hotwood hall and as a special treat come
and see middleton's very own flamboyance
and flamingos and our endangered
potteroos
minister i i thank him for uh his kind
invitation i'll certainly keep it in
mind and the government is absolutely
committed to reforming technical
education uh through new uh t levels and
uh that's why we're investing a further
65 million uh to uh develop uh teacher
retention and uh and support and
recruitment for teachers in nfe as for
the potteroos uh in in his area i will i
will bear that are
is good they wild
will i will do my utmost to cameron
inspector rebecca longbertly thank you
mr speaker my constituent laura told me
that remembering sunday hurts
it hurts because there have been no
medals for her granddad's service and
the thousands of men involved in nuclear
weapons tests overseas between 1952 and
1991
it hurts because studies of such
veterans have shown increased
miscarriages increased birth defects and
the same rate of genetic damage as
clean-up workers at chernobyl and it
hurts because the uk is the only nuclear
power on earth who has denied
recognition
so i asked the prime minister will he
recognize nuclear testing veterans today
and agree to meet them the leader of the
opposition has
prime minister well i'm grateful to her
for bringing this to my attention and i
will certainly uh make sure that we get
a proper meeting uh with the
representatives of uh the nuclear
veterans that she uh that she raises
orlando thank you mr speaker
when i was in greece with save the
children i learnt that change at any
border was quickly communicated down the
line
if migrants and asylum seekers knew
that they would be directly returned to
france or taken to a third country
pending application
if they knew this
would they risk a dangerous and illegal
crossing and make their way to france in
the first place can i ask my right
honourable friend what further
measures are being considered because
this is an issue of great concern any
spawn along the coast along the country
and uh i'm anxious to be able to
reassure my constituents that there are
uh plans ahead
prime minister
i thank her very much and she has much
relevant experience in her work for for
save the children in greece uh our only
credible way of fixing this mr speaker
is with our new plan for immigration and
that will be made possible with our new
nationality and borders bill uh which
will make it possible for us to
distinguish at last between those who
come here legally and those who come
here illegally mr speaker and i hope
very much that it will command the
support of the whole house
thank you mr speaker
in may
part of norfolk station in my
constituency
collapsed i've asked the transport
secretary to intervene and build back
better and fairer to allow access for
people with disabilities he's declined
my kind offer i'll ask the prime
minister to intervene no bluster
substance
better and fairer norfolk station it's
in the north of england thank you
prime minister well i'm i'm i'm tempted
to invite the uh uh
to wait and see uh what we do for a real
uh funding tomorrow but i will look
certainly i will certainly look at what
he has to say about northwich station uh
with keen interest sarah
over 4 200 service women and veterans
use a democratic process to contribute
to the defense select committees
inquiring to women in the armed forces a
formal response is still awaited from
the mod now whilst the majority of women
enjoy a fulfilling career in the
military shocking issues were raised
around sexual assault bullying and
harassment i know the prime minister
agrees with me that they are our armed
forces are the best in the world would
he also agree with me that we need to
make sure the british army is the best
place to serve as a woman yeah
prime minister
i i think i thank my uh honorable friend
and she's campaigning on a very very
important issue i think
too often uh we find that our armed
forces fail to provide the wonderful
women in our armed forces with the
support that they deserve and that's why
i'm pleased that my my normal friend the
defense secretary has secured a
parliamentary inquiry into this uh for
the first time and it's vital uh that we
support and encourage women in our armed
forces who make a massive difference uh
to those services especially thank you
mr speaker
it has cost businesses in northern
ireland the 850 million pounds to date
to operate the field and suffocating
article uh the field and suffocating
protocol lord frost is today in belfast
when will the prime minister fix this by
legitimately activating article 16.
prime minister
i i thank the honourable gentleman and i
think the the word i will fasten on in
his question is is legitimately and
there is no question that the uh the use
of article 16 which after all has been
done uh by the eu uh commission to stop
vaccines being exported to this country
uh is something that is perfectly legal
and within uh within the bands of the
protocol
jen hunt thank you very much mr speaker
i recently visited humphrey perkins
school in beautiful barrow ponce
the students asked me there what is the
government doing to engage children and
students from all backgrounds to
encourage them to aspire to become an mp
and even the prime minister
prime minister i think what i would say
to
my honorable friend and her and us and
our students is that uh nothing and
nothing that is said or that takes place
uh in this house uh no none of the uh
the rj bhaji the repartee uh the uh the
occasional abuse uh to which we subject
each other mr speaker should in any way
deter anybody uh from seeking a career
in politics but it is a wonderful
privilege and we are all mr speaker very
lucky to be here
here here
speaker in my constituency of edinburgh
west we're now finding
numerous people coming to us with delays
from dwp
in uh pensions and benefits to add to
the delays of what
others are facing over passports in dvla
can the prime minister tell us please
amongst the many jobs being done at the
moment who is making sure that the
departments of government are running
smoothly and quickly the minister
uh i i thank and i i think actually that
the department of work and pensions
under my uh right on friend the
secretary of state uh has been a
government has performed outstanding
service uh performed miracles and uh
amongst the things that it has achieved
uh mr speaker uh is to help to get uh
millions of people uh effectively back
into employment in spite of all the
difficulties that we have faced uh we
now have uh our unemployment running at
virtually record lows in spite of all
the difficulties we face all the
difficulties we've faced in this
pandemic as we come out of furlough and
that is largely thanks to the work of
the dwp of course there is more that can
be done and people can always uh up
their game uh mr speaker but i i think
the dwp the officials working in the dwp
across the country huge numbers of men
and women have done an outstanding job
final question jake murray mr speaker in
july 2019 i was in manchester when the
prime minister committed to build a new
line northern powerhouse rail between
manchester and leeds it was a third
commitment reaffirmed in our manifesto
in november 2019
and last month reaffirmed in the prime
minister's conference speech in
manchester were the voters of the north
right to take the prime minister at his
word
yes mr speaker
and they should wait and see uh what is
unveiled tomorrow uh where he where mr
speaker he may learn something to his
advantage
thank you very much mr speaker i've just
received on the wires that the leader of
the opposition and i didn't hear this at
the time because of so much noise called
the prime minister a coward
surely that is in breach of earth in may
and improper and should be withdrawn
can i say there was a lot of language
that i couldn't hear today and i
certainly don't want words covered is
not what is used in this house and i'm
sure that leader opposition would
withdraw
i withdraw it
but he's no leader
tim farron
pushing it today come on
speaker alongside the honourable members
for uh birmingham old southwark and for
rice slip northward and pinaran are a
friend in the other place the bishop of
durham we've been pressing ministers in
the home office to permit a cross-party
visit to the napier barracks on
september the 7th the minister for
future borders and immigration declined
our request for an in-person visit and
indeed the home affairs select committee
will also refuse to visit in july on
october 27th we again requested an
on-site visit and asked the minister to
respond by november the 10th we have
still yet to hear anything despite the
independent chief inspector of borders
and immigration and her majesty's
inspectorate of prisons finding earlier
this year
serious concerns and failings in the
provision of accommodation at napier
barracks the government has extended the
use of nafio barracks to 2025 and stated
the site will be used to pilot design a
future accommodation for asylum seekers
so you can see mr speaker that a visit
is now more than pressing could you
advise me mr speaker whether it is in
order for the government to refuse
access to this important site to members
of parliament
can i first of all say
i'm grateful to the honourable member
for giving notices of punch border it is
for the government to decide whether to
invite members to visit the barracks
that said the use of the barracks has
been a matter of public concern and
debate
and of course i would always encourage
the government to agree to such requests
from honourable and right honourable
members not least to ensure that they're
able to hold the government to account
in a well-informed manner
i accept that there are occasions which
is legitimate for the government to
refuse to request for a visit for
example on security grounds and i should
stress that i do not know any reason for
refusal in this case however
the government benches will have heard
my view that in principle i would hope
that such requests for visits can be
accommodated and at the very least i
hope the home office ministers will
discuss the matter properly with the
honorable gentleman and i'm hope that
that doesn't take too long to contact
him point forward to martin docker to
use
mr speaker no intention to take a point
of order until i heard the prime
minister's answer to my honourable
friend the member for wrexham in
relation to their chairing the
subcommittee on women in the armed
forces the prime minister indicated a
parliamentary inquiry
i think based on that report given that
we've seen a tenfold increase in
reporting of rape and sexual assault of
women under the age